here's what would happen if there were  an alien civilization on Proxima B  meet Proxima b a planet that registers  at 0.87 on the Earth's similarity index  that's close though Proxima B is similar  to Earth life forms on this Alien Planet  would likely develop very differently  for terrestrials living on this planet  would need to be able to withstand  radiation yeah the planet receives about  400 times more x-rays than we do on  Earth unfortunately we likely wouldn't  be able to visit the aliens anytime soon  using current Technologies it would take  between nineteen thousand and eighty one  thousand years to reach them but hey  maybe they are Advanced enough to travel  here first  so do you think they exist because